quelles sont ces ombres que ça vole et
bien c'est l'ombre c'est madame la
béquille qui est paralysé depuis 15 ans
et qui est dans une petite voiture hôtel
vraiment paralysé tellement vivant ça
c'est un autre problème
oh on comme on le sait après une
vingtaine de bus nos réalités c'est
cette eau même qu'un parce que monsieur
labbé a tué sa femme il faut bien
manager tsm fils a obligé un devenir
l'étrangleur d'autres femmes c'est
vraiment une peut pas faire autre alors
qu'est ce qui vous intéresse dans
affaire visiblement c'est pas simplement
l'intriguent c'est le rapport entre ces
deux hommes il est d'ailleurs qui se
doute de quelque chose et le chapelier
qui oui c'est à dire que ça ça
m'intéressait aussi mes skis ce qui m'a
vraiment ce que ce que je trouve
absolument fascinant c'était que le film
montre la désagrégation mentale de
l'individu sur le chapelier devient
devient fou dans le sens au total du mot
sert que finalement ils pédalent
complètement dans la semoule et et en
même temps au moment où ils arrivent
dans un état de folie définitive ces
moments où il atteint la lucidité ce
moment c'est le moment où il s'aperçoit
de son état réel il fini par l'accepter
parce qu'auparavant alors qu'il étrangle
des vieilles femmes qui sont les copines
de sa femme qui doivent venir la voir
pour son anniversaire donc il est bien
obligé de l'été puisqu'il veut faire
croire que sa famille donc c'est logique
de régler ici une logique imperturbable
mais il est devenu un assassin à seat
france et à partir d'un moment d'un
moment le film bascule parce que il lui
manque un cadavre c'est à dire que la
dernière des personnes qui doit tuer est
déjà morte et c'est comme un type qui a
prévu une course 2 est une course de
1000 mètres qui s'est arrêté à 750 il ya
250 mètres qu'il reste dans les jambes
et les chevaux chapelier cadavres qui
traite comme ça en l'air et ça commence
à devenir très grave pour lui il fallait
en effet un acteur important est un dieu
pour jouer un rôle aussi difficile c'est
traduire leurs futurs veulent
terriblement difficile surtout que il
n'hésite pas à être extrêmement drôle en
même temps je veux dire c'est un film on
rigole pas mal les familles gitanes
benoît ne rigole pas mal et c'est grâce
à michel et c'est pour ça qu'il nous
fallait absolument parce que sinon on
n'aurait pas pu pousser aussi loin sur
bensen étonnante ascension tonnelle de
michel serrault depuis une vingtaine
d'années lente au début on alloue on n'a
pas du tout utilisé michel serrault
cinéma et puis il faisait simplement
rire et ne voit pas du tout des rôles
dramatiques
c'est assez c'était tonneau mais c'est
un jeton actuellement shakespearien dans
le sens total du terme c'est à dire que
lille est capable dans la même phrase à
la fois de vous faire rire de vous faire
réfléchir de de vous émouvoir c'est très
très impressionnant
alors voyons un deuxième extrait de ce
film c'est à dire que ce héros le
chapelier fait visiter la chambre de sa
femme de ménage c'est bien cela oui
c'est nécessaire c'est à bonn qui a
disparu comme il fait explique oh et
puis comme il l'expliqué au commissaire
de pays ce qui est fait pas mieux de vie
des émissions de prix c'est une
caractéristique il est complètement
abrutis tout le tout le monde tout le
monde l'ofce dans la ville
voyons donc cette confrontation entre 0
et le commissaire de police
n'avait pas la jouissance de l'armoire
ah bon la première d'avoir remporté ces
affaires sont bons tout est là curieux
elle avait aussi un imperméable la
gueule juste à cause de l'etranger que
je suis un que je comprends ça
et ouais
vous l'auriez pas à verser ce jeune adam
ii dans les environs vous ne saviez pas
qu'elle avait un amoureux non non mais
je ne faisais pas attention à ce qu'elle
faisait mais ça ne m'intéressait pas
elle a un caractère très renfrognée
plutôt grognon bon je vais garder cette
photo je la donnerai à mes services
c'est comme vous voulez ça je vous dis
franchement vous faites comme vous vous
pensez alors vous disiez un instant que
michel serres ont fait partie de ces
comédiens qu'on n'a pas besoin de
diriger à qui on n'a pas besoin
d'expliquer les choses celui bon alors
ça signifie quoi semons la mettre en
scène c'est pas qu'on n'a pas besoin de
les diriger et cirque il faut il faut
qu'on fasse le même film mais il suffit
d'en parler avant et ensuite on a on a
vraiment pas de n'a vraiment pas de
surprise on a plutôt une palette et ont
choisi cette palette les couleurs qu'on
veut c'est très c'est très agréable
c'est à dire que vous savez diriger un
acteur c'est ou bien on choisit un
acteur et il correspond à ce que vous
voulez et à ce moment là vous ne vous
êtes pas trompés il suffit de le
conduire tout tranquillement à bon port
et de le mettre de bonne humeur fait
qu'il soit d'humeur égale que qu'ils ne
continuent tiennent à son personnage et
c'est tout si vous avez choisi un
mauvais acteur si vous essayez de lui dû
faire dire phrase par phrase qui donne
ce qu'il doit dire il sera pas meilleure
donc la direction d'acteur c'est c'est
le choix de l'acteur passe avant le film
beaucoup oui et puis au moment du film
on se rend compte six si on ne s'est pas
trompé non seulement bon il paye avec
celle d'un acteur qui sont mauvais dans
des films dans la mesure où le rapport
entre ce que vous voulez faire et la
façon dont la cure jo n'est pas bon mais
ça c'est surtout de vote alors là de
temps en temps vous pouvez vous vous
pouvez modifier le jeu d'un acteur mais
je me méfie beaucoup des acteurs qui
disait tu dis ce que tu veux et je te le
fais en général effectivement ils le
font mais ils ne font jamais d'une façon
extraordinaire
moi ce que j'aime bien quand l'acteur me
surprennent cette agréable et les bons
acteurs essaient toujours de de
surprendre les gens qui sont derrière la
caméra et avec ce héros on était surpris
à chaque prise c'est être mais pas
seulement avec zéro d'ailleurs faut dire
qu'avec tout ce jeu j'ai eu l'âge ou la
mort pourquoi est ce que le film est
réussi je crois parce que j'ai eu la
main heureuse pour pour les acteurs même
pour les seconds rôles là la fameuse
bonne qui a disparu là je vais pleurer
triskell jamais fait de cinéma ça fait
le christine poligny et qui est
absolument formidable et enfin bref je
me suis pas trompé sur souvent je me
trompe sur les filles
et là je ne suis pas trompé dire que
monique chaumette est formidable aurore
clément était patente bref moi je vais
pas faire toute la distribution tout le
monde gueule mais mais c'était bien
content de ne pas m'être trompé alors
trop de charolles revenons-en votre
carrière vous avez fait une quarantaine
de films à peu près aujourd'hui avec ce
succès qui se confirme les fantômes du
chapelier est ce que vous pouvez dans
vos films détacher ce qui vous semble
plus caractéristiques de votre style si
tant est qu'il y assez chabrol écoutez
je suis très difficile de savoir quel
est son propre au style on veut dire
qu'on fait des films comme on respire on
peut donc être difficile de si on un
style trop voulu on s'en aperçoit bien
sûr mais les autres aussi et c'est un
jeu
competo qui est une espèce d'évolution
vers une simplification de la forme tout
en se je crois que ça se tient au fait
d'abord qu'on est con et de moins en
moins et pathé par l'instrument c'est à
dire que quand on a joué beaucoup avec
après on se calme
justement vous le dire la caméra caméra
de lot l'attirail canton quand on a
percé les problèmes et les petits
mystères qui pouvait y avoir après il
son père c'est donc il faut trouver
autre chose on s'aperçoit que le ski ce
qui est important définitive c'est le
style est le plus clair et le plus
précis et le plus profond dans ce qu'on
raconte
et pour ça il faut il faut être très
très limpide au niveau de la forme ça ça
s'appelle le classicisme et là c'est ce
qu'on appelle le classicisme et les gens
n'aiment pas souvent de catéchisme mais
je crois que le classicisme et il le
fait déjà
oui j'ai 51 ans qu'à partir de 50 ans il
vaut mieux de classiques sinon on fait
un petit peu le délire des celtes
ruchêne c'est le quai petit tee shirts
et guillaume et cachette d'un c'est la
gigue
je crois qu'à partir d'un certain âge il
faut au contraire essayer de faire des
films des films simplement fait est ce
que c'est une façon de dire que certains
de vos confrères de l'anneau l'ex
nouvelle vague qui ont donc aujourd'hui
50 ans comme vous et qui continue de
faire des films dits l'avant-garde sont
des jeunes vieux ou des vieux j'ai pas
du tout non mais je pense que nous ont
fait un joli là non je pense à personne
je vous promets le caler le sans lequel
le cas de nouveau question sont jamais
innocents
mon cher philippe et dans 4 jean luc je
trouve que il va bon il continue à faire
de la recherche bien entendu puisque
c'est vraiment son c'est vraiment son
destin de faire de la recherche et mais
je trouve qu'ils vazel on part donc en
visite dans lucky série bien ce genre de
grever si le riz est chauve qui y vint
il va
vers une espèce de classicisme de cette
recherche c'est à dire que lcl cesse
d'être d'être provocation pour devenir
approfondissement je trouve je trouve
qu'il ya un énorme progrès contre que
passion par exemple est ainsi
d'infiniment pu plus intéressant que les
films provocation qui faisait aux
alentours des années 60 aux regards
aucun regret de n'être pas allé à cannes
mais je suis allée 48 heures à cannes
pour vendre le film nous étrangers de ne
pas avoir fait partie du festival afin
non seulement aucun regret mais je
trouve que la sélection française
le principe de la section française je
sais pas j'ai pas vu les films et je
crois que le principe des sanctions sans
cesse de prendre des gens qui ne sont
pas encore allés à cames et c'est
excellent mais je crois qu'il faudrait
que ça soit comme ça tous les l'ennui
c'est que ceux qui sont allés se tenait
ne pourront pas y aller mais prochain
merci beaucoup claude chabrol pour votre
présence et se filme les fantômes du
chapelier demain nous vous parlerons
direct de roland garros elle comme
invité principal jean loup dabadie 20h
ce soir votre rendez vous d'information
et patrick poivre d'arvor aubenas poids
mini